[Music]
let's talk about religion this week
whether you're a believer or a
non-believer religion has and probably
always will play some role in society
this is why religion has been at least a
part of so many of the discussions I've
had on this show
from interviews with an atheist like Sam
Harris to a Catholic like Bishop Aaron
to a Christian like Dinesh D'Souza to an
Orthodox Jew like Ben Shapiro to
ex-muslim Yasmin Muhammad to atheist
Muslim Ali Rizvi to Jew turned atheist
turned Christian Andrew Klavan and so on
all of these religious descriptors
exists for each of these individual
people no matter how confusing they may
be to anyone from the outside looking in
I for one have consistently enjoyed
talking to people from all walks of life
and seeing what they believe and how
they took or did not take the leap of
faith to get where they are in their
spiritual journey as I've said many
times before I myself am NOT a believer
but I don't really care what anyone else
believes as long as their religious
beliefs don't take the form of
legislating my life in the privacy of
your own home you can believe in Yahweh
Jesus or Muhammad or the Flying
Spaghetti Monster and that's actually
none of my business if your religious
beliefs give you some sense of purpose
or inner peace then great it's when your
beliefs bleed into who i can marry or
wanting to throw me off a roof that i
have a problem with you and your beliefs
as for that leap of faith i usually
explain my feelings about belief with a
simple basketball analogy if you told me
that you saw LeBron James dunk from
half-court last night well I couldn't
just take that on faith alone I need
some sort of evidence like at the very
least seeing videotape with my own two
eyes as proof of your outrageous claim
so it seems only logical to me to treat
the biggest questions of the universe
with the same intellectual rigor as my
imaginary basketball analogy belief
aside there are many attachments people
have to religion which often are
cultural and based in tradition for me
being Jewish is a connection to the
history and often very painful history
of the Jewish people but also being
aware of the traditions rich cultural
heritage and historical ties that
I have to the people who came before me
well I'm not religious myself
it's the educational emphasis of Judaism
which left a theists like Albert
Einstein or Carl Sagan stay connected to
their cultural identity without giving
up their commitment to logic and reason
without comparing myself intellectually
anywhere near those two legends it's
this type of understanding of Judaism
that I believe in but I have no desire
to push this on you or on anyone else
joining me to discuss belief religion
and why Jews are so funny is Rabbi David
Wolpe of Sinai temple here in Los
Angeles
rabbi Wolfie was named America's most
influential rabbi by Newsweek magazine
and one of the 50 most influential Jews
by The Jerusalem Post where a Larry
David and Jesus and half of Lenny
Kravitz fell on that list we'll soon
find out
[Music]
joining me today is an author a
columnist and the rabbi of Sinai temple
right here in Los Angeles Rabbi David
Wolpe welcome to the Reuben report thank
you I feel like we've already spent 45
minutes together that's right now good
up to repeat everything you're gay I
actually didn't tell you the truth about
many of my opinions up to this point so
it's fine right I'm in a little
bait-and-switch like that's really right
that's right all right so there's a lot
I want to talk to you about okay it's
Monday right now it's yeah it's about
Monday or Tuesday what the news day it's
Tuesday see I didn't tell you the truth
about that either so it's Tuesday
afternoon what does a rabbi normally do
around three o'clock on a Tuesday
afternoon normally I have meetings I've
meetings with staff I have meetings with
congregants for a vice for counsel for I
meet with various charities I mean with
Bar Mitzvah kids I meet with wedding
couples I write I teach weddings
funerals all those sorts of things yeah
so you're sort of on call all the time
sure yeah sure I have hours does a rabbi
have hours you have hours where you meet
with people but you don't necessarily I
mean is somebody sick in the hospital
you don't say I'm sorry I can't see you
it's you know it's not a good time right
but you have hours where you have
essentially office hours where you make
set meetings yeah so I thought a good
jumping-off point for us would be that I
saw that Newsweek called you one of the
50 most influential Jews yes so the
question is were you above or below
Larry Dave so that was Jerusalem Post
actually did that who wouldn't lose
because we called me the one for about
seven or eight years Newsweek strangely
judged the most influential rabbis in
America so one of the years I was the
most influential rabbi in America which
means that I really hit the sweet spot
because in the thousands of years of
Jewish history for seven years they
ranked traveller and I rank in rabbis
what I mean is they got three people who
said okay this is number one this is
number two so you can't take these
things too seriously right and an
influence is a very amorphous thing
and no I'm not as influential as Larry
dad is everyone clarity for it or nearly
as funny or creative okay but for the
record that was the Jerusalem Post yes
and not news we are but the reason I
wanted to start with that question was
because I think at least sort of in my
world most of the Jews at Amer Adam are
a lot of Jews I'm Jewish that there is a
cultural attachment to Judaism that's
separate sort of from the religious
Fridays of Judaism that rabbi that's
probably not the thing that you want to
hear first but that does seem to me what
sort of the average secular Jewish it's
and this is one of the things that
separates Judaism from Christianity that
I think most Christians and many Jews
don't appreciate which is Christianity
as a religion if you believe in Jesus
you're Christian if you don't believe in
Jesus you're not Christian Judaism is a
religious family so you're born Jewish
the only way to leave a family's to
choose another family but as long as you
don't choose another family
you can dislike your family many of us
do right they're still part of the
family so Jews have this very close
connection now these two systems they
each have advantages and disadvantages
the advantage of having a religion is
it's much more easily spread because if
you have somebody with a completely
different culture who says I believe in
Jesus they're Christian like you are the
advantage of having a religious family
is Jews feel a powerful sense of
connection to one another and that's why
we Jews are in trouble in a far-flung
land you can be sure that there will be
a Jewish rescue attempt you can be sure
of it because you feel that familial
connection in a way that Christians
don't do you do you think there's some
sort of risk in in separating the
religious side and that familial side
that heritage side well I for me I don't
think Jew I don't think Judaism can
survive as a cultural phenomenon without
religion I mean it's what we'll Herbert
called cut flower ethics that if you
remove flowers from the soil in which
they grew they'll last for a generation
or two but then they'll disappear and I
think the same thing will happen with
Judaism over time without the religious
roots that nourish it
we'll eventually disappear yeah so what
is it about Judaism that has allowed so
much secularism and so much science and
thinking and learning and education all
the things that for people that don't
like religion caste religion always
tells you what to think and religion
hate science and all those things but if
you look at you know the hundred
greatest scientists of all time half of
them are usually Jews or this other
thing so part of it is that Judaism has
a fierce intellectual tradition if you
and if you study Talmud there are
arguments on every single page and and
that tradition of argumentation was
always true and status was given to
intellect that is it's not that wealth
didn't have status in the Jewish
tradition it did like every other
society but you want it to be you want
to marry the rabbi I mean that was he
was the leader of the community and he
had the social status and you became a
rabbi by knowing more really it was a
knowledge competition more than anything
else and when you have that that sort of
intellectual tradition once you liberate
it from being solely a religious one you
get these trained intellects that look
around the world and and hungrily became
experts not just in science in medicine
in music in mathematics in chess I used
to be a tournament chess player it's
astonishing how many of the world
champions of chess have been Jewish and
it's all to say I think it's all the
same cultural tradition yeah do you see
sort of a chasm between all that
scientific knowledge of math
mathematical knowledge and all that and
then sort of the that you have to take a
leap of faith to believe in God which is
sort of the reverse of what science
would I thought of the reverse I
actually don't think it's the reverse I
I mean I understand how people could see
it that way and some do see it that way
but I I think that the more you know
about the world and the more you
appreciate the wonder of the world and
sort of the iron laws of nature the more
you almost feel like what Robert Jastrow
the physicist said he says as as the
physicist peers over the horizon he says
he feels like he sees a God who knew we
were coming but why does the world have
such laws
I visit obey such laws what created a
system that we could figure out and why
is it that we have minds that presumably
were just jerry-rigged by evolution
right there's no reason why our mind
should be able to figure out these
things and yet we're in consonance with
the universe I mean I think that the
idea that there is a designer as science
presumes there's a design makes perfect
sense so I'm sure as a rabbi in LA you
probably have a lot of skeptics in your
community I got a few you know you've
probably got a couple 80s in mathematics
and all that generally those people are
not they're not thought of as apostates
or no instead they're still part of the
family right how do you have that
conversation with them weirdest is have
you ever had you know someone confusion
I just don't know sure all the time and
some of my books actually address
exactly that in and as you know and as
we talked about I've had debates with
with a bunch with Christopher Hitchens
and Sam Harris and Richard Dawkins and
on all these very articulate and and
well-spoken atheists I really do think
that a lot of this is your orientation
towards the world and it's not so much
it's not so much an intellectual
decision in the sense that when I teach
Jewish theology and I've taught it for
many years at a bunch of different
universities so I've put up all the
classical Western proofs for God the
teleological proof in the cosmological
book I've never had someone look at the
board ago oh now I believe that right
because even though we pretend it's a
purely intellectual argument it's not
and you can see that when you see how
emotional people become atheists or
believers when they start to argue this
it's really deep in us this orientation
towards the universe so I think that the
best argument for religion is to be in a
religious community for a while and see
how it helps you see the world
differently yeah so when you talk about
a religious community let break down
some of the okay different religious
communities for somebody that's watching
that has no idea what's going on with
those crazy Jews yeah what the basic
three that at least we have a big the
big three in the bathroom we got a
reform conservative s an Orthodox can
you to sort of break down the Bayshore
by the way I do want to point out that
you said to me right before he said no
question is off the table that's true I
don't know what kind is horribly maybe
gays over ah that's alright so I've
gotten to my I've got myself into enough
trouble already
well yes already here and he said no no
no no no in in life yeah um so the first
first of all orthodoxy now I'm going to
give you not my perspective on them but
their self definition okay orthodoxies
self definition is that it believes it
is true to the Torah that God gave Moses
at Sinai thousands of years ago and the
authoritative interpretations of the
rabbi's of that Torah which essentially
are untouched by history they're really
they live above history and and so the
decision of the authoritative rabbi
today was in some sense either literally
known to or in theory known to Moses
thousands of years ago that's worth a
taxi yeah okay look for the literal part
so yes so these words are too and the
words in the Torah are literally what
God spoke maybe God didn't speak the way
I speak right it doesn't have to be
literally doesn't mean literally the
literal interphase but they are exactly
the words that God intended Moses to
have in the Torah thousands of years ago
okay the conservative movement assumes
that the tradition grows and changes
that it is decided essentially by the
community of devoted Jews that that
community grows and changes to and that
history has a very profound impact in
the way that people see themselves their
community and that therefore the Torah
has to constantly be subject to the
interpretation that takes into account
what we know about the world that our
ancestors did not know the reform
movement places its emphasis primarily
on individual choice and individual
liberty also tends to have a strong
social justice and progressive political
orientation yeah
how would that must be the most
difficult part of being a rabbi or any
clergy member what's the political part
that you see it is Ron rust into
politics all the time
it's hard to define the most difficult
part but it is a difficult part because
my and some rabbis are very political my
own orientation is to be as little
political as is possible which doesn't
mean not at all but my assumption is
twofold
first of all there are people in my
congregation who know as much about
politics as I do so for me to get up
there and preach to them because I read
an article this morning is is hubristic
and presumptuous or as we would say it's
pathetic
yeah the second is that I know very well
that you can look at the Jewish
tradition and say Judaism says and come
out with a very right-wing agenda or a
very left-wing agenda and both of them
will have lots of verses and and lots of
rabbis to quote and so when people
presume that Judaism speaks in either a
right or a left voice I think they're
they're wearing blinders what do you
make of the state of Jews in America in
2017 if there's always an article every
year the Judaism Judaism is over there
done that the other thing there was
others wise I guess it's not great it's
not there was a there was a professor at
Brandeis a philosopher many years ago
named Simon robideaux vich and he wrote
an essay called Israel the ever dying
people and he quotes Jews in every
generation to say we're the last after
us there aren't going to be anymore I'm
an optimist by me or I'm hopeful by
Nature let me put it that way so I
presume that Judaism is going through an
interesting sometimes painful
transformation what it will be in a
hundred years I don't know what I do
know is that no one would have predicted
a hundred years ago where we are now so
I try to stay out of the profit business
because I see that people would i watch
Sunday morning talk shows and here are
presumably the best inform conducts in
the world and they're wrong at least
fifty percent of the time so for me to
presume that this thousands of year old
tradition in this complex land I know
what will happen especially because I'm
aware that what will happen to Jews in
America
has more to do with what will happen to
America the mobile happened to Jews if
you had said to a Jew in Germany what's
what's Judaism in Germany going to be
like in 50 years in the year 1900 they
would have looked at the Jewish
community and been completely wrong so a
lot of it is sometimes there's returns
to tradition there's a systolic
diastolic movement I assume Judaism will
survive and what exact way I don't know
yeah I can already tell we're good we're
going to kind of bounce all over the
place while we do it if you mentioned
about Sinai before I did that's where
Moses got the Ten Commandments according
to the to the lore I went to Mount Sinai
in 1997 I was 21 years old I went
through Egypt I went I went from Israel
actually through through Sinai was a lot
safer at the time yes was I'm like a
overnight bus ride and I made it to the
Sinai and you're supposed to hike it
they tell you to hike it's something at
like midnight so that it's cool right by
the time you get to the top it's sunny I
got there like 8:00 a.m. and I ended up
hiking in the middle of the day I hadn't
eaten some pigeon in Cairo and I was it
was a mess it was enough to put it
mildly I got to the top of Mount Ida the
first time someone told me a story about
having bad pigeon but we headed in and
Edward but I got the time tonight and I
truly remember thinking this that if if
God exists that I will get some sort of
sign right that Moses saw the Ten
Commandments here I'm gonna get some
kind of sign I got up there and it's
pretty happy been there but yeah yeah
that's pretty barren there's a little
there's a guy that actually works there
and he sells water and so that's it and
there were like two other people and
they were quibbling over signing and I
looked around and they were no bushes
there were some twigs and things and you
know nothing happened and I realized
that that is only sort of stuck with me
like I was ready for it I was 21
yes finished Amsterdam for two weeks
before that doing god-knows-what maybe
that's where you got the sign I probably
I decided Amsterdam very possibly but
but that experience I'm doing rap
recording before so I I think part of it
is that the moments of illumination
sometimes come to you in at times that
you're not looking for them
unaware and if you think back over your
life
and you think of moments where for
example you intensely connected with
another human being or where you felt
inspired by the beauty and the wonder of
the world for no reason other than you
were inspired by the beauty in the
wonder of the world what I would say to
you is that's a sign I moment it may not
have happened at Sinai it may have
happened you know I don't know they've
happened in Simi Valley but but it's a
Sinai moment and and fidelity to the
moment is more important than fidelity
to the place
Simi Valley is actually very similar
additional right exactly yeah that was
slick that is pretty similar so the
battle I think between sort of religion
and the cultural part of Judaism is this
do you think this can sort of be
reconciled I think that there will
always be people who love being Jewish
but don't have a religious orientation
or religious feeling and and that's I
mean and many of them will make
fantastic contributions both by the way
to the world but also sometimes to
Judaism I mean Theodor Herzl was not a
religious Jew but he made an
unparalleled contribution to the Jewish
people into the Jewish tradition so it's
complicated and I and I am I am as as
you've probably already intuited I'm
really not a bright line person I'm not
like this is the way you have to be and
if you're not this way then you're
outside of the ambit of what's
acceptable because I just I think the
world is awash with gray yeah but is
that right they're sort of uniquely
Jewish that concept that a rabbi would
sit across from you and say that I'm
sure I find a priest that would say and
I sure and you can find a lot of rabbis
who won't say it yeah I think I could
probably find a lot more rabbis that my
creation that might be and one of the
reasons again this is at least part of
the Talmudic tradition there is a
there's a statement there's a there's an
impure animal it's called a share it
means a lizard basically and and in the
Talmud it says that somebody who can't
give you 70 reasons why this impure
animal is pure shouldn't be a wrap
those if you can't argue the contrary of
what it is you know to be true then you
don't have the intellectual agility to
be a rabbi which means that you are
trained in some sense to see both sides
and and if you if you have an empathetic
heart then you realize that it's pretty
rare that something is so clearly black
and white that you can't imagine the
other side now there are such things
obviously and even things where you
can't imagine the other so it doesn't
mean that you don't sometimes condemn
them but but I always I always assume
that that you that life is richer and
and the human experience is more
elevated if you can manage to get at
least a scintilla of understanding of
what the person across from you thinks
yeah so when you see someone like like a
Larry David or a sense other somebody I
could bring almost anything back to
right constantly when you see them sort
of offering that version as of juice
sort of like you know New York or LA
ultra-liberal has you know sort of a
religious but there's a cultural
affinity or Larry to in Curb Your
Enthusiasm but he sort of has an
absolute aversion to religion and all
that do you see that as a is it a net
good because he's putting some sort of
Jewish ideas out there or do you see it
as well he there's a what do you spend
on religion or just his take on what
bothers me about it is the ignorance of
it because here you have a tradition of
thousands of years of devotion and
brilliance and exploration of life and
meaning and it's reduced to a joke about
corned beef so there's part of me that
thinks gee it's wonderful that these
creative funny Jewish minds are doing
things they're creative and funny and
calling them Jewish but there's another
part of me that mourns the loss of the
realization that you have made a deep
rich foundational tradition of Western
civilization into shtick and that's too
bad
why are you sunny well the traditional
answer is Jews are funny because in
oppression you don't have that many
outlets for hostility or even to
alleviate hostility and one of the
things about humor that I mean people
know is that if you feel something very
deeply even if it's pain and you make a
joke it makes it a little bit better I
read once that meet you the philosopher
said that wit closes the coffin on an
emotion you feel something and you don't
want to feel it you make a joke and it's
gone so there Jews have had to feel a
lot of things they didn't want to feel
yeah so that I mean there there we could
go through the list of them but that's
part of it forget the 50 greatest rabbis
we go to 100 greatest comics no question
probably 70 of them right would be
Jewish yes so that you think it's a
punishment changing that huh as other
immigrant groups and this is the second
part of it which is the outsider also I
think sees so you get a different
perspective of the world if you're not
ensconced in it if you you know as the
idea that some whoever discovered water
wasn't a fish right you have to be
somewhere outside in order to see what
what it is and the outsider view is also
part of comedy do you think you sort of
lost the cred as the outsider because
we've been sort of hunted and hounded
and I grew up knowing yes Holocaust
survivors and everything else and but
now because use it become depends where
you are so I think Jews and Beverly
Hills aren't outsiders but I think you
go to Jews in France even though they
may be wealthy or Jews in Hungary and
they feel pretty outside still and this
is that this is the genius and the
wonder of America that I think people
don't appreciate enough first of all any
Jew who's not who's American who isn't
patriotic is an idiot and doesn't know
anything about history or about their
own about the country or their own
people but the reason that America is so
much better for Jews is that it's not
because Americans are nicer than people
elsewhere and it's not because we have a
great Constitution because they're of
other countries that have wonderful
constitutions and tyrannical governments
it's because elsewhere in the world you
had throughout history Germans and Jews
Hungarians and Jews Jews were always the
identifiable other in America you don't
that in America what you have is this
salad of groups there are Koreans and
african-americans and Jews and Hindus
and Muslims and Protestants and
Catholics and on and on and on and on
thousands of groups so Jews have never
been the identifiable other it's not
like everybody got the government set it
off like that there are Americans and
Jews yeah and so that's why yeah we
don't have the same sense of being
outsiders as we once did but that's a
good thing so I've a couple times on
this show mentioned something about you
know there's that great lineup from
fiddler on the roof' where you say
somebody tell you something to the
effect of you know we're the chosen
people I just wish somebody buddy out
there I think a lot of Jews feel that
that feeling of wait a minute wait a
minute is this whether you're a believer
or not believer they say we're the
chosen people but you look at the
history of the Jews from the Holocaust
and pogroms and being kicked out of
virtually every other country United
Wendling Jews in France right now
everything else this is an odd how do
you reconcile that with a choice in so
if you're actually between people well I
would say in fact the it goes back to
the to the answer that we were just
talking about which is if you are the
identifiable other and you refuse to
assimilate into the mainstream then
people will resent you and it was not
wouldn't that be a great argument for
just assimilating and recalling your rap
if you think that the whole world should
be the same and vanilla is the only
flavor yes but if you think that the the
proliferation of traditions is a glory I
would say glory to God but certainly a
glory to humanity then though and I
think that most of us would believe that
resisting being like everybody else is
inherently a good thing even though for
most of history it was seen as a bad
thing I think in case Jews were right
and so in medieval times when they
didn't want to be Christian or they
didn't want to be Muslim despite the
fact that it was resented I think that
that's tremendous it costs them very
dearly and by the way over the
generations many many many Jews did
disappear so you have populations of
people all
over the world who have Jewish ancestry
who have no idea that they have Jewish
ancestry let's shift to Israel for a
little bit let us something to the Jews
right a little bit better so so I know
you can make many arguments and I'd be
happy for you to lay them out you know
religious arguments for the reasons that
Israel should exist as a state I think
you can make many secular argument I do
take as much sense historical sense
right that has nothing to do with God
giving this group of people this ayah
grand all right well let's start there
then because I thought you were going to
go more on the religious side so let's
talk about historically I just think
historically here's a people that you
know that inhabited that land that had
that land always wished to return to
that land that was forcibly exiled from
that land and return to it so there's my
wrap that up fitting a rap day exactly
all right so when people say oh wait a
minute the Palestinians lived there now
I know we can sort of do we want to do
this hiring we can do this for the next
hours of our just do a couple minutes
okay so here goes up before here's a
couple minutes one of the things that
people don't realize is there never was
an independent state ever in that area
yeah after Israel was destroyed
thousands of years ago there wasn't a
Palestine it was always part of a bigger
Empire it was never a separate country
until 1948 when it became Israel ago
meaning it was part of me out of it it
was part of the Ottoman Empire was part
of the Roman Empire it was always part
of someone's empire it was never a
separate state if you come to a place
and also there is the reality that in
throughout history when people have come
to a place and they built it up and
they've made it their own it's become
their own now a lot of origins of States
are lost to prehistory we don't know how
France became France I assure you if we
did it would involve war and conquest as
the beginning of every state inevitably
does the question now is les the origin
of it than the disposition of it that is
how is it that you accommodate the
different people who live in that land
in a way that makes it possible to have
peace I don't think that it is too much
in a world that has 48 Muslim states to
have a Jewish one and I don't think that
most of the world thinks that it's too
much so we when the UN focuses so much
on Israel
which of the media is constantly
attacking Israel and so much of what I
see it from the modern left not really
from the right anymore maybe well there
has a right where it depends where go to
URIs through it through an American
right through an American land yes
this endless focus on Israel this place
that's the size of New Jersey right that
is one Airport right that at one point
without the West Bank is about six miles
wide it's absurdly tiny what is that
focus is that just not chosen people
thing again so I I think that it's a lot
of different things is there an element
of anti-semitism unquestionably I mean
anybody who denies that is being
ridiculous of course there is it's also
the fact that don't forget the Jews are
still the the origin of Christianity is
Judaism and and Christians and Jews had
this sibling rivalry that got enshrined
unfortunately in the New Testament
because you know the family quarrels are
sometimes the most bitter so that that
always the existence of Jews in Israel
always has a special meet today a much
better one but for a long time a very
negative one to Christians and end and
that venom continued on even in people
who left Christianity unfortunately and
then in the Muslim world the the
confluence of a political and and a
clearly anti-semitic ideology made it
you know made it basically so that
Israel had almost nowhere to turn and
the UN is just a moral swamp it's just
immoral see I mean when North Korea you
know I mean when when Libya is on the
Human Rights Council and whether it is
running women exactly it's just a moral
swamp it's such a I look I've done some
work with the UN and I just want to say
for the record there are things in the
UN that do really wonderful work around
the world but as an institution it's you
want to throw your hands up and say
really this is the best that humanity
can come up with yeah well certainly not
the best event now in love with but
right yet yet here we are here we are
that focus though that sort of focus and
it's interesting you said there has to
be a piece of anti
autism related to the I sort of
relentless odds what I always find is an
interesting situation with the questions
that I think you sort of alluded to
maybe it used to be that rivalry but now
if you look at evangelicals Network for
Israel and Christian sport in general I
bet you that statistically it's probably
higher than Juno right I can say I know
I've had that experience that I've gone
on trips to Israel at times when there's
been like an Intifada or whatever
the only other groups that are there
Christian groups Jewish groups aren't
there and you say to yourself this is
this is an extraordinary really an
extraordinary phenomenon and the amount
of genuine goodwill in the let's just
talk about America now in the American
Christian community the right America
Christian can be I'm talking about the
right wing now is because that's what
Brit evangelicals almost all are not all
but almost Allah is extraordinary it's
really extraordinary look I I mean I've
had this experience I this experience is
enshrined in one of my books one of my
books that book called why faith matters
the preface was written by Rick Warren
now the idea that an evangelical
minister would write a preface to a
rabbis book about faith about today
that's just that's a that's a different
world let me tell you a beautiful story
I had a I had a professor wonderful man
named Eliezer slow-moving and and he
came from Eastern Europe and and he
learned when you healer when you go by a
church you spit that was what he was
taught as a child because they all want
to kill you that's what he learned all
of his family went through camps he
escaped but he went to a labor camp lot
of his family died in the Holocaust he
comes to the United States he starts
teaching at the University of Judaism
now called the American Jewish
University there's an interfaith
conference in Berkeley and the president
of the University tells me I want you to
go and he says I'm like oh no way I'm
going an interfaith conference no way
I'm going to sit there with Christians
and and but he's an immigrant he's new
and the president says you got to go so
he goes the opening meal the minister
who's leading the meal says I would like
to begin this meal the way our Lord
Jesus Christ would have begun the meal
Barakat adonai eloheynu melech ha'olam
hamotzi Lechem min Haaretz
which is the Hebrew blessing over bread
and Eliezer said he started to cry he
didn't know that the world could be as
different as it was when he was growing
up and and that's what it is to leave
now and to live in America in an odd
twisted be serb or shellfish because
that I would have met that I don't know
I don't know but but good of you to add
all right so the interfacing you
mentioned is that an odd place for a
rabbi to be because there's nothing
about converting other people in Judaism
right you're not well yes I know
no you're not looking I mean there is
something about there before Constantine
and before was made a capital crime Jews
did convert people who not who were
monotheists but who are non monotheists
so an interfaith thing that was not
really a conversion it's an opportunity
for people to talk about their beliefs
and you can certainly learn from other
religious traditions I don't believe and
I don't think that anyone should believe
that Judaism has a monopoly on truth
I've learned a lot from Christian
ministers I've learned a lot from
dialogue with Muslims so I think that
that's a good thing with Hindu I've had
gurus at the synagogue it's had the Dali
Lama at the synagogue I think that's a
good thing right right so I'm not saying
you specifically but just generally the
idea that Jews aren't looking to
proselytize know now that it's so that
it's a little different so that you do
an interpreting where I got a third you
and the third Christians and the third
Muslims well the Christians and the
Muslims would love to have those use
convert right right I mean that is it
they would they certainly yeah that well
that is a fundament it is a fundamental
difference not all Christians not all
Muslims feel that way but yeah Jews
basically feel they said it stated
several times in the Talmud that
whatever the world to come is the
righteous of all nations have a place in
the world to come so I don't have I
don't need to save your soul because if
you're a good enough person you're saved
because Judaism believes that it's how
you act in this world that makes the
difference it's not whether you believe
X Y or Z so yeah we don't have the same
motivation we have a motivation towards
goodness more than we do a motivation
for
specific belief so let's talk about the
afterlife a little bit okay
I'm all in favor of it yeah I think I am
a big fan you'll be a little bit expand
afterlife I can tell you do let's go be
reduced a little Larry to it uh but
there's no that well there's no heaven
in Hell right well not exactly I mean
there is a Judaism tends not to define
exactly what happens to you after you
die
and and that makes sense because as soon
as you start to define it starts to
sound ridiculous
Mark Twain has a passage in letters from
earth where he says people think they're
going to list sly on green fields and
listen to harp music as they would want
to do it for five minutes while they're
alive
maybe they'll be happy for the rest of
eternity doing it after they die what I
would say that Judaism says is that
human there's something about the human
being that is eternal and just as you
could not have anticipated this world
before you came into it you never would
have imagined like bricks and eyes and
tuna fish and ideas and words I mean who
would have imagined you can't possibly
imagine what another world is like but
there is one so does that change the
ability for doubt the ability I guess
the actions that you take other out
there like everything in Judaism that I
know is sort of about life it's like
it's here it's now right is this kind of
thing well I do not when I like that I
like that's why I think it's so
important here because you don't want to
be you don't want to act here like a
again that's put in the Talmud like a
servant for a reward you're not doing
this so you get that if you do then
religious life has no meaning the whole
point is to do it because you think it's
worth doing right that's what goodness
is goodness isn't being good so that you
get a reward goodness is being good
because you believe in goodness right
hopefully just for the for its own sake
actual right right so when you
conceptualize God I mean is it a
conscious being I mean is God watching
us right now if God have YouTube and
what do we talk about it um I think God
doesn't need you to I don't mean to
dampen your your no doubt
gigantic audience but um so the way I
put it to the high school kids is I say
look to a 14 year old I said remember
imagine when a two year old can a two
year old imagine what a 14 year old is
like no not only can you not a two year
old cannot can't imagine it they can't
even imagine what it is that they're not
able to grasp we are in Jewish reckoning
the distance between us and God is
infinitely greater than the distance
between a two-year-old and 14 year old
so I don't begin to know what God's like
and I wouldn't begin to say yeah God's
listening to us which is a very
anthropomorphic conception of God all I
do believe is that you can live your
life in a way that is in conformity with
the way you were intended to live or
less so that's what I know so there are
moments so I think in some ways I put a
greater emphasis on godliness than I do
on God that is the way that I believe
God wants us once in quotes because
again once as a human thing wants us to
act without worrying too much about what
God is like because I know that I'm
incapable of beginning to understand
that could you do all that without God
you could the question that I always
wonder is does that stick not for a life
I mean there's there could be a theists
who are kinder than any religious
believer I know a lot of good atheists
I'm sure you do too the question is as a
society does that get transmitted
generation to generation if you don't
believe that there's an ultimate
standard that transcends us and I'm
deeply skeptical that that would happen
so what do you make about sort of the
general state of religion altogether not
not just you but the general state of
religion in America in 2017 I mean by
those polls we see that in America yeah
the amount of non-believers is growing
tremendously atheists growing
tremendously Jedi's up there which I'm
okay with that one do you do sense that
religion as an institution is weakening
in America I think I like the way you
ask the questions because the question
because I think what is weakening our
I think institutions in general don't
have the appeal that they once did
people don't want to sit in buildings
and pray they want to go out they want
to be on mountaintops they want to be on
hikes
I think the feeling that religion speaks
to is not lessening but I think that the
organization and the institution speaks
less to people than it once did way to
do about that as a rabbit you got a nice
big building I think you're right
exactly well actually it's funny because
I just I have an article coming out this
week in the Los Angeles Jewish Journal
about writing about about taking
services outside part of the reason is
that I think that especially younger
people don't feel connected to the
buildings that they didn't build after
all the generation before them built
this building feel great about it but
but they inherited it so what'd you do
about it I think is you reconfigure
religion and when I said earlier that I
didn't know what Judaism would look like
in a hundred years my assumption was
that it will look different and one of
the ways that it'll look different is I
suspect that it will reintegrate into
the natural world in a way that we
haven't so far in at least in America
and and I don't what do you mean by that
I mean that that the the idea of of
worship in nature and the idea not a
worship of nature but worship in nature
the idea of meditation and alternative
ways of connecting to the Jewish
tradition and using the learning of the
Jewish tradition to open as opposed to
to only have narrower communities will
become a greater and greater trend so
you will have probably two different
kinds of Jewish communities ones that
are more self-sufficient and more
institution based and others that I
think are looser and broader something
like the sort of Orthodox ones that you
referenced earlier they'll they'll keep
all that sort of older stuff I think
although there are challenges to
orthodoxy that's going to be very hard
for the community to and the principal
ones are the challenge of the position
of women which is a constant issue in
the
DOX community and inclusion LGBT to
inclusion which is also a challenge to
be with our community yeah so we're in
LA you said I could ask you anything yes
I see these ultra-orthodox guys out
there it's a hundred degrees yes in Los
Angeles they're wearing a big wool coat
right a big wool hat this can't be what
God wants come on well you're walking
down Wilshire the reason that the very
well then so Apple is early so the
absolutely the right exactly that's the
point the point is that that dress
wasn't originally Jewish dress it was
the dress of Polish nobleman in the 19th
century which is why as a conservative
Jew I say history clearly affects the
way Jews practice but at a certain point
people who are if not conservative and
reactionary what they what they tend to
do is they take a period in history
which is the ideal period and they try
to recreate that period over and over
and over and over and over again
wherever they are wherever they go like
the clock has stopped it's a strategy
that works in some ways but I think in
other ways is unproductive so all right
is that fair enough
you mentioned LGBT community that you
were for gay marriage what like
something like years ago yeah years ago
before before it was legal right here
yeah how did your congregation take it
did you have to take counsel with other
rabbis to show you wanted well the avis
etc I mean the uproar was so great in my
congregation that when I announced that
I was going to do gay marriages it would
literally was on the front page of the
New York and the LA Times
that's how upheaval --is-- to coin a
phrase it was there were a lot of people
not really sure it was legal in
California but not right legally right
but not legal and what was before the
Supreme Court decision um my
congregation and I had waited until I
thought it wouldn't split my
congregation apart my congregation was
many I mean many people were very
supportive I don't want to paint with a
too broad a brush many were very upset
part of the reason that many r upset is
not only because some were conservative
but also I think there were some I again
don't want to paint with too
brought a brush but I have Mike makarios
about half from Iran and many who had
emigrated from Iran for them this was a
giant cultural shift that they really
didn't like so for me it was here was
that here was sort of the contrast that
I was struck with I knew that it was
going to be I didn't know it was going
to be quite as big as it turned out to
be I knew it was going to be big and I
prepared it I taught a series of classes
and so on and then I wrote a letter
about why I was doing it and before I
sent it out I wanted my daughter to know
she was at the time I guess about 15 14
or 15 I wanted her to know because she
was going to hear stuff and I she went
to a school with a lot of people from
the congregation and I thought people
might say bad things about me and I
wanted her to know what I was doing so I
said Samar I said I just want you to
know I'm sending this letter out to the
congregation to say that I'm going to
start doing same-sex marriages and she
looked at me strangely and she said what
took you so long
and I realized yes that's the point the
point is that this is a huge
generational shift the biggest one I
think maybe humanity has ever seen in
one generation from the people for whom
it was really inconceivable was like I
was saying I was going to marry Martians
they couldn't imagine how a rabbi could
even think of doing such a thing
to someone who said well I was like I
was saying to her I'm now going to marry
people who are blond the people who are
redhead right so it was incredible so
I'm curious man well first of it strikes
me that you're you're in a particularly
unique situation because generally
American Jews are liberal your ex you're
in a congregation in Los Angeles we're
on the west side of Los Angeles that is
not liberal but as your client mine's
not liberal that's sort of like just a
fascinating it is insider mix you need
to what you're sort of dealing with
there so when I've had other people on
that event have argued from a Jewish
perspective when we talk about marriage
so when I've had been Shapiro and Dennis
Prager on and we've talked about this
kind of thing
both of them have basically got it to
the point of saying they're not really
for it but that this is where they
libertarianism sort of takes over so
just get the state out of it and I don't
care I yours doesn't seem to come from
that no no no I think that that's I I
don't let me just put it this way
without it's only individual I don't
approve of that point of view and I
don't and I don't honestly have a great
deal of admiration for it
well I think I'm not just for the
government should be a division or
government you get out of your right to
marry and that's that well because they
because the only reason that they're
saying that they didn't feel that ten
years ago the only reason that they're
saying that is because the cultural
backlash against saying you know the
government shouldn't do that is too
great so I think that they're being
forced into a more moral position but
it's not because they advocated and if
you think that it's okay for if you
think that people shouldn't do it then
don't say people shouldn't they wouldn't
say that about abortion I mean if you
really think that there's a moral issue
here then stand up for the moral issue
and make a case for it for the record I
basically said that because I because I
think there is a moral issue here and a
moral issue here is that when someone
comes to me and says it's not you know
the the other day there was a there was
a cover story on this said about about
people who've come out in the gay
community in the Orthodox community and
how they're struggling with it and and
as I read through it I just thought
there's not enough of an acknowledgement
that your sexual identity it's
fundamental to who you are it just is
it's not like the clothes you wear it's
not you know that I don't like mushrooms
it's not I'm a vegetarian it's not
nearly as fundamental to me right as my
sexual identity right so when someone
comes to you and says this is how I was
born this is how God made me and if it's
not whatever connection of genetics or I
didn't choose this is who I am and
you're telling me that in the Jewish
tradition there is no place for me to
express my love to the only kind of
people that I can love this way who can
say no to that I mean who can say I'm
sorry but you have to put away who you
are
because there's a verse in Leviticus so
I think a lot of people are going to be
watching this beer and other
non-believers but some people who are
believers of whatever and they won't
like this but oh I was going to say the
reverse I think they're gonna say holy
[ __ ] I've been waiting for someone know
why I say that I mean look some of the
most moving experiences that I've had
have been a result of this in fact the
most I have to say is this sounds very
strange but it doesn't didn't sound
strange to me the most romantic moment I
have ever seen at a wedding was the
first wedding I did between two men and
and I can tell you I mean they taped to
the whole thing I'm sure that they won't
identify the book one of them turned to
the other they decided they wanted to do
bowels and and so I said sure if you
want to do balusters wedding you do
balusters wedding so one of them said I
want to tell you when I decided to marry
you one night you fell asleep first you
always fall asleep first and I was
looking at you and I started to cry and
I woke you up and you said what and I
said you have to promise me that I'll
die first because I can't stand the idea
of being in this world without you and
you look at me with just infinite
tenderness and you said I promise and
then you fell right back asleep but at
that moment I decided I wanted to marry
you and when he said that first of all
there was not a dry eye in the house and
I thought anybody who would witness this
moment and say this is an abomination ah
I have known I have a very hard time
with yeah so all right so then so you
make this decision now that strikes me
also is somewhat unique because you
don't have to clear that with anyone
right like the conservative might mean
no it has regular conservative movement
does not right the conservative movement
has the latitude some do and some don't
but they knew yeah and I let my
congregation I let the key people my
congregation know that I was going to do
this but I didn't ask their permission
yeah what do you mean some do and some
don't meaning others I'm conservative
rabbis will do gay marriages and some
well oh so there isn't something like
written in the right now guide it's like
a party platform so there is right there
is there is a committee of law and
standards but they basically said you
know you're going to have to make this
decision on your own
yeah did you go to find counsel with
some other rabbis another
I read a lot of what was written about
it but I knew that I wanted to do it I
mean I didn't
my question was tactical my question was
how do I do this with minimum damage to
my community because what had happened
to me was several years before a young
man who was gay came to me and said why
won't you do gay marriages and I said
I'm going to give you an answer but you
won't like it I said but here's the
truth I want to I said but I sort of
feel if you'll forgive the grandiosity
of the analogy I feel like Abraham
Lincoln did at the beginning of the
Civil War which is you don't issue the
Emancipation Proclamation before you're
ready I said if I do it now it's going
to tear my community apart I said I have
to wait until they're ready
it'll still be a big thing but it won't
tear them apart because I'm the rabbi of
a community that wasn't good enough for
him I completely understand that yeah
but that was my job were you ever able
to reconcile that with him yes really
yeah I came back to him and I said this
is why I and I I don't know I don't know
he still would have preferred I'm sure
that I had done it years before but at
least I did it and also I think he was
pleased at how big a splash it made
because that made him feel proud yeah
you know what kind of backlash did you
get I had a lot of people who threatened
to resign although only a couple did and
at least of the couple who did one came
back I got a lot of really not nice
letters attacks one of which I shared
with you some private some public and
and also but the hardest part really the
hardest part was that I hurt people that
I really care about because there were
people who were like good people and
kind people and and they and they
identify with their rabbi and they can't
how could you do this that's how I felt
was like how could you possibly do this
yeah but I told my daughter again to
return to my daughter during the Boer
War Churchill said it's exhilarating to
be shot at without result and I said to
her I said there the lesson here is if
you really believe in something the
people who love you will still love you
and and sooner or later the world will
move on
and you will have the satisfaction of
having done what you know what you know
is right and and you'll survive so it
was in that sense it was it was a
beautiful experience even it was a hard
one how do you navigate those other
political pieces because I'm sure
there's a constant battle between trying
to remain yeah its money land and also
what a clergyman is legally allowed to
do well there are political few but
there are different kinds of political
pieces I mean there's politics in the
synagogue itself and then I actually
wrote I occasionally write columns for
time online and I wrote a column against
repealing the Johnson amendment the
Johnson amendment is the one where you
shouldn't do I don't think rabbi should
endorse candidates I think that that's a
mistake and you shouldn't ask them to
because then you're going to have the
Republican show in the Democratic show
and that's not good yeah
but my basic political orientation is I
will be a firm supporter of Israel from
the pulpit and any other venue I can but
am I going to take a position as a rabbi
on taxes no am I going to take a back
position on on most political issues I
think that it's not my I will do it
interpersonally you ask me personally I
will tell you but as a rabbi I think I
only got to take a position on things
that are clearly of Jewish where I think
that Judaism speaks fairly univocal II
on them you know do you get pushed into
sometimes having to talk about things
that you don't have a look yes I do
sometimes which okay that's fair I mean
it's not as though it's not as though
you don't have a community and they
don't have a say
sometimes they have a say too you know
and they say we really want you to talk
about this and tell us what you think
when I gave I told you I gave the the
invocation at the at the Democratic
National Committee a lot of my
congregation was very upset at that I
said to them listen if the Republicans
had asked me I would have done that I
said I think if a major political party
asks you to give a blessing as a clergy
you give a blessing so in fact the next
month or two months later they had a big
Republican Jewish dinner and they said
okay come give the invocation I secured
let me out
and I ran I did it but but there's an
example of like they had a clear say and
they were right to say I don't want my
rabbi to be a Democrat or a Republican I
wanted to be a rabbi yeah
when I've talked to a few people on this
but Dennis Prager particularly talked
about sort of the judeo-christian roots
around United States and that that we
need those I was basically arguing that
if we were just be governed by the
Constitution if we could just follow the
words in this document that would be
enough for the civil pluralistic society
that we want and he basically was saying
that no we need to stay rooted in this
judeo-christian idea is that well I
wonder I am not enough of a
constitutional scholar to answer this
question adequately but I wonder if you
could make the argument that the
Constitution was in fact rooted in that
judeo-christian idea and there's a sort
of dovetailing of your to our own so I
think that that's sort of where we ended
up leading is that there's enough of it
sort of in the framing right of what we
went with with the Constitution I mean
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator I mean
that's the Bill of Rights but still yeah
that there's some some stuff in there I
feel like there's so much more we can
talk about you know we'll circle back to
finally some people that we talked about
the beginning so you mentioned that you
you've debated Tim Harrison yes
Christopher Hitchens and Richard Dawkins
some of some of my favorite people and
you know Prager and Shapiro and a couple
other people do you think we're losing
the ability to do this now this wasn't a
debate what we did here right I really
wanted to hear what you saw what about
these things but just a general concept
of sitting down with people and and
being ok with some ideas that you would
agree with or disagree with I think what
what I think what we are losing to some
extent some of the people not all some
of the people that you mentioned there
are perfectly willing to sit down and
talk with people who differ with them
what I think that they're not always
willing to do is to be prepared that
their ideas might change and and part of
the reason that that's so is because
even though many people won't say it
I know this is a rabbi you get captured
by your own constituency and what
happens is if someone who has a presence
on TV or radio or whatever if they say
something that's different from what
they've been saying before because
they've changed their mind they will get
a gigantic onslaught from the people by
the way who they like and who are their
followers and who are their supporters
and they'll say how just as I mentioned
with gay marriage how could you do this
to me that you always said this and now
you're saying that so there's a
hardening and part of the hardening is
not the hardening of the person only
it's a hardening of the constituency
behind the person so that's that's a
tough one
that is a tough one I I mean I had this
experience sometimes when I would debate
the god stuff and I felt like the person
and I'm sure was true of me although I
like to think not as much the person on
the other side would make a concession
to this argument or that argument but
they'd be letting down the home team
mm-hmm so they didn't that's sort of the
hardest thing to do a hard thing to do
yeah I a couple weeks ago when that
whole Bill O'Reilly thing happened where
I was getting fired I tweeted out
something to the effect of I said I
don't know the specifics of what he did
but the fact that we revel in such
public destruction at struggle I think
is dangerous yes and the tweet took off
but I also was getting an insane amount
of hate or and then someone found a -
somebody searched a tweet of mine from I
think 2011 and found a tweet where I
where I was sort of reveling and Keith
Olbermann and wanted to talk firing
Brian Trainor and they sent it to me and
they said see you see you hypocrite and
I normally don't respond to people that
are coming after me but I just wrote yes
type of a huggers well I can I thought
just that and then I got a lot of
accolades for that but I thought this is
so dangerous the sort of thinking that
if you thought something once you can't
you can't change it and also I'm I'm not
a big advocate of the charge of
hypocrisy I really prefer the charge of
imperfection because the truth is yes I
know a lot of people for example who
defend traditional marriage and they've
been married five times and you say to
them they're hip
crits but the answer is no part of it is
you can believe something and really
think that it's good and still either
not be able to live up to it or be
disappointed in yourself I really I am
if you think of imperfection then it
gives people more latitude to change and
more latitude to admit that they did
something shouldn't have done if you're
constantly ready to pounce it freezes
people into positions that I think are
unhelpful so it's so interesting because
you say that and a few other things you
said they strike me as very not
religious things now I understand I
receive your very my point about they
are directly religious no I understand
that and that's so so you're framing
them with it within your understanding
here's my here's my basic my basic core
most people would would hear that last
piece about being able to change and
evolve and accept this and that is just
not and what I would say is repentance
and admitting what you've done wrong and
the realization that all human beings
are flawed that's the heart of the
religious tradition and this idea that
you have to jump on someone whenever
they do something that's bad that that
to me is antithetical to the tradition
that I was raised in certainly so
alright so one more for you now about a
half hour ago was it during the break
you we took a 10-second break you said I
think it was on air you said that you
could beat brigitte sending i should
give me a great flag bring a five-minute
ending on freedom and liberty and
western values and individualism and all
of this stuff so give me some great
piece of jewish wisdom for people that
are just trying to find a little a
little peace in the universe these days
because i think that that's what people
out being looking for we're not being
competitive with a decision i would
imagine
which i would not do it cuz i you know
appreciate my our friends and i would
like to read into i'm fighting this
directly to brigitte good this is what I
would say what people have to realize is
the power that they have to change other
people's lives in an instant because all
of your viewers and all of your
listeners know
the people have said things or done
things that change their life even
though they never go back and tell them
you know that to the third grade teacher
who said this I never forgot it and it
changed my life and that realization
that people can change and change each
other is is crucial it's pivotal and
it's powerful and I will close with a
story that illustrates it so there was a
rabbi a rabbinical thing to do it's a
very rabbinic order and here goes it's
one of my favorite stories so there was
a rabbi who used to travel around the
world and he would sing and play music
and his name was [ __ ] Carlebach he was
in his time very well known I used to
live on the Upper West there you go you
know Carl dr. Carl Baugh synagogue
there's a crow about Seneca so once
after the collapse of the Soviet Union
he went to Eastern Europe and he was
playing in the small community in the
former Soviet Union and he had the
experience where everybody was cold to
him they all like closed the door either
literally or metaphorically in his face
except for one guy and he spent all
Shabbat all the Sabbath there and at the
end of it before he left he said to this
guy he said listen I understand why
these people don't want to hear from me
I know that they went through you know
the Second World War and that the the
jackboot of communism and with the fall
of the Soviet Union more things and then
they have shortages and and winter he
says what I don't understand I don't
understand you this is why are you so
opening and why are you so loving and
why are you so welcoming why are you so
different and the man said I can tell
you exactly why and I'll tell you when
it happened look he said I'm an old man
and I have lived in this town my entire
life and I remember before the first
world war it was the dead of winter and
a rumor swept through the town that the
Cossacks were coming and they were going
to loot and pillage and burn and destroy
so all the parents from the town
gathered up all the children they
brought us to the rabbi's house and they
ringed around the rabbi's house all
night long and he walked up and down
between the rooms where all the children
slept and I was curled up in the corner
of the rabbi study but I couldn't sleep
because it was bitter cold and in the
middle of the night the rabbi came up
Hynde me and he took his cloak off his
shoulders and he spread it over me and
he said good child sweet child
you know said the rabbi de kalb ah it
has been almost 80 years since the rabbi
spread his coat on me but it still keeps
me warm those sorts of moments they're
not just nice they're sacred
their religious moments you can do them
for someone else
in an instant almost every day and many
years from now even though you might not
know it it will still keep them warm I
think you match Brigitte did you did
rabbi well Peter it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you and for more on rabbi
well be well you can find him at sinai
temple in los angeles and follow him on
twitter at rabbi will be thanks
[Music]
you